you
[Music]
your Majesties your excellencies ladies
and gentlemen I stand before you here
today to accept on behalf of my mother
Hong sang-soo Qi this greatest of prizes
the Nobel Prize for peace because
circumstances do not permit my mother to
be here herself I will do my best in her
place to convey the sentiments that I
believe she would wish to express
firstly I know that she would begin by
saying that she accepts the Nobel Peace
Prize not in her own name but in the
name of all those men women and children
who even as I speak today continue to
sacrifice their well-being their freedom
and their lives in pursuit of a
democratic Burma
this is the price and theirs will be the
eventual victory in Burma's long
struggle for peace freedom and democracy
[Applause]
speaking as her son however I would add
that I personally believe that by her
own dedication and personal sacrifice
she has come to be a worthy symbol
through whom the plight of all the
people of Burma may be recognized and no
one must underestimate that plight the
plight of those in the towns and
countryside living in poverty and
destitution those in prison battered and
tortured the plight of the young people
the hope of Burma dying of malaria in
the jungles to which they have fled that
of the Buddhist monks beaten and
dishonoured nor should we forget the
many other senior and highly respected
leaders besides my mother who are all
incarcerated it is on their behalf that
I thank you from my heart for this
supreme honor the Burmese people can
today hold their heads a little higher
in the knowledge that in this far
distant land their suffering has been
heard and heeded
[Music]